سعيا لتمكين مؤسسات الحكم الانتقالي من
اجتياز هذه المرحله الحساسه في تاريخه
وابدت استعدادا كاملا لنقل الخبرات وبناء
الشراكات المفيده للدولتين وهي تطورات
التزمت بها جميع الاطراف السودانيه وعززت
من مصداقيتهم تحقيقا لتطلعات الشعب
السوداني
وقد اصبح كل ذلك مهددا نتيجه الازمه
الراهنه حيث تتحسب مصر من خطوره ان يؤدي
هذا الى احضار ثمار التضحيات التي قدمها
الشعب السوداني من اجل الحريه والتقدم
والازدهار والتي ظلت وتظل مصر سانده
وداعمه له باعتبار ان السودان تمثل العمق
الاستراتيجي الطبيعي لمصر سعيا لتحقيق
التكامل المنشود بين البلدين في مختلف
المجالات الحيويه استنادا لواقع تاريخي
وجغرافي اثبت بما لا يدع مجالا للشك
وبالرغم من اي اختلافات مرحليه في وجهات
النظر حول بعض الامور ان مصلحه مصر لا
تفترق عن مصلحه السودان وان مصلحه السودان
تكمن في مصلحه مصر
وان مصير ابناء وادي النيل هو مصير مشترك
نابع من ماضي متشابك
السيد الرئيس الساده المندوبون الدائمون
السيد الامين العام المساعد ختاما
اكدت مصر وما زالت تؤكد التزامها الاصيل
بدعمه واستقرار السودان ووحده اراضيه
وتؤكد على اهميه عدم تدخل اطراف خارجيه في
الشان الداخلي السوداني
وتعرب عن تاييدها المتواصل للنموذج
السوداني القائم على الشراكه بين المدنيين
والعسكريين في المرحله الانتقاليه ووضع
الاسس الصلبه لبناء نظام ديمقراطي راسخ
ومستقر
لذا تؤكد مصر على اهميه قيام الاطراف
السودانيه بتسويه النقاط الخلافيه ووضع
الحلول السليمه والواجبه التنفيذ للخروج
من الازمه الحاليه وضمان عدم تكرارها
وستظل مصر تتابع عن قرب وبشكل مستمر
تطورات الازمه الراهنه وتكثيف الاتصالات
الثنائيه والاقليميه اللازمه لتحقيق ما
تقدم مع الترحيب بقيام جامعه الدول
العربيه ببذل كافه المساعي من اجل معاونه
جمهوريه السودان في اتخاذ التدابير
اللازمه لانهاء هذه الازمه بشكل قابل
للاستدامه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات